so what we're saying that when you look
at Islamic teaching to summarize it for
you Islam came to preserve five things
all right Islam came to preserve five
things
so the first one Islam came to preserve
religion
so what does that mean when we say Islam
reservation mean that in Islam
worshiping Allah alone
worshiping the true God is very
important that's why paganism atheism
politicism is forbidden
because I will demonstrate to you later
on what is the outcome of not worshiping
the true God okay so Islam came to
preserve that secondly Islam came to
preserve the intellect
that's why in Islam alcohol and drugs is
forbidden because it affects intellect
yeah
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why interest and gambling is
forbidden okay fourthly Islam came to
preserve marriage
that's where fornication adultery is
forbidden lastly Islam came to preserve
life
that's why committing suicide killing
people and Justice forbidden but we have
to understand when Islam forbid when
Islam came to preserve that notice by
just saying stay away from it no there's
a barriers
because Allah wants good for mankind
and if we break these five Necessities
then what happened to us let us go back
to no Worship in the true God if you do
not worship the true God we start
following our own desires the outcome of
that bro we can observe that you know
the camera they work blurry we can
observe that yeah
now man wakes up if he gets a woman
a woman wakes up Vick is a man
it doesn't stop here bro now people are
waking up he says I believe I'm a dog
but I'm trapped in a human body
yeah brother it's not normal you
understand this is not normal and the
problem they are trying to force that on
us
you know there's a guy he raped two
women
he raped two women yeah
why they smart why did so he was going
for a trial so he knew they're gonna
find him guilty he went and he dressed
like a woman and he said on this paper
yeah he identified himself as a woman so
what what do they have to put him away
for him now he's in Paradise that's
Paradise for him that's what he wants
you see and that's what Allah mentioned
the Quran and the meaning of the verse
if the truth follow people desires the
heavens and the Earth be corrupted
that's why the Islamic legislation
against people desires because what
people desire is I want to like you want
to do crazy stuff you understand that
will harm us you understand so likewise
if we don't worship the true God alcohol
drugs what is interest interests make
the ritual
instead an interest is a type of slavery
for example I know okay I know you need
you need money yeah and when they do
they study
how are people not how people can pay
and so on so I know you need seven
thousand Pounds
and I think you know what I know by two
weeks I'm gonna tell him listen I'm
gonna give you seven thousand pound you
have to give it back to me as ten
thousand in two weeks but I know you
cannot do that so by two weeks I
suddenly said no problem I can't wait
for you what you do give me more and
keep adding and put that on a big scale
so I'm making myself richer that's why
when you look at those who are very
hostile to Islam because these five
things is good for us individually
collectively these five things Islam
came to preserve and the opposite of
this five Universal Necessities drugs a
fornication interest that destroy our
societies individually collectively
that's why I'm majority of times those
who are very hostage Islam those who are
in power
you know why because I'm making money
from these vices that's it so imagine
they're making money how gonna be mad
Rich so what they're gonna do they hang
on the only Revolution that is going
against our agenda and our desires is
Islam okay we are rich so what we're
gonna look we're going to look to what
is the most effective weapon to stop
Islam which is Media